hey leute heute gibt es kein rezept
heute verschönern wir unsere wohnungen
haben sie und ich sind vom paar monaten
hier eingezogen werden der ende märz
unsere hochzeit und seitdem kam in die
ganz viel auf einmal und wir hatten
nicht die gelegenheit hier alles so ein
bisschen schöner zu machen und
einzurichten
insbesondere der balkon denn damit
starten wir jetzt hier am anfang des
videos kommt einfach mal mit ich nehme
auch direkt im bodenbelag mit und dann
kann ich euch mal zeigen wie der
aussieht also viel zeit haben wir hier
noch nicht drauf verbracht und wir
werden jetzt zuallererst den boden
verschönern dass die zielzone stallboden
und da werden wir jetzt ganz einfach
diesen darauf verlegen und das sind
jetzt im zeitraffer viel spaß
[Musik]
nummer eins der boden ist erledigt die
wir gebraucht
20 minuten das nein mir kam es vor wie
eine stunde in der halbe stunde
aber es ging eigentlich ratzfatz und
macht schon richtig was her
und wir haben auch schon möbel gekauft
die möbel haben wir nicht einfach so
gekauft ich bekomme nämlich morgen noch
unterstützung von der lebenssaft
das ist eine interieur designerin oder
inneneinrichterin ich weiß nicht wie man
es nimmt ich frage sie morgen und sie
hat einfach dieses auge dafür
ich habe ihr ein foto von meinem balkon
geschick eine skizze und sie hat mir
gesagt das und das und das und das
einkaufen und genauso habe ich gemacht
und daher werden wir jetzt schon im
vorfeld die möbel auch noch dazu
aufbauen und zeigen dass euch auch noch
mal im zeitraffer sagt
[Musik]
abbruch abbruch es regnet hamza abbruch
es regnet
also wir machen morgen weiter ist 20 uhr
das regnet gerade und morgen machen wir
weiter und zeigen euch dann so den
zwischenstand
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt in köln und ich hab euch
ja gesagt triff jemanden ganz besonderen
und sie steht auch schon vor mir ich bin
total aufgeregt weil ich jetzt auch das
erste mal sehen ich treffe hallo schön
dass uns endlich mal persönlich
kennenlernen geklappt genau lassen uns
gerne mal ein paar minuten setzten
erzählen meinen zuschauern wer beladung
und was machst du eigentlich ja ich bin
ja für all die die mich vielleicht noch
nicht kennen
sacher von safa living von meinem
instagram account und was ich mache ist
eigentlich wohnungen verschönern
wohnlicher zu machen das mache ich genau
das machen sie auch mit unserer wohnung
und darauf freue ich mich schon total
wir haben hier schon ein bisschen
vorgesagt der ball komisch und halbwegs
eingedeckt durch deine hilfe
er hat die sache nämlich auch alle
informationen für whatsapp geschickt
oder sowie und wir gehen jetzt zum
ersten laden und es heißt es wir gehen
einmal hier vorne in köln zu h&m home
und schau mal ein bisschen nach
inneneinrichtungen und nach dem waschen
sikorski super größer
fussball
[Musik]
nein
es geht
[Musik]
es werden
b
[Musik]
sollte
geht das
dohmen
das kann
juni
[Musik]
dass du das 6
besser
[Musik]
nein
ein
st
das war die letzte station wie beim
baumarkt und was machen wir morgen
schönes morgen komme ich zu dir und
danach den rest werbig ich freue mich
traurig auch also bis morgen in niebels
blick gelte zwar die motion die us-kinos
herr des trentino 6
[Musik]
die sich im rücken eines denken mir tun
nein
[Musik]
hier geht's werbung denn ich kenne sagte
mcgregor dienstag nummer zwei mit saffer
zusammen und wir waren ja heute schon
fleißig einkaufen in essen oder mehr als
dass wir haben den ganzen wagen
vollgehauen und jetzt müssen wir nur
noch eins tun nämlich das ganze schön
umsetzen und zwar fangen wir mit dem
balkon an wir machen nämlich den ganzen
sichtschutz sie einmal dran und dann
geht's schon an zwei tuner waren nämlich
die schöne deko nicht komplett angegeben
geshoppt haben okay ich freue mich mega
drauf und ihr seht das ganze jetzt im
zeitraffer viel spaß dabei
[Musik]
nur vize pitsch
hommel
[Musik]
nicht
hallo ihr lieben ja wir sehen könnt bin
ich hier welche die skizzen und wir
haben gerade den balkon fertig gemacht
wie ihr sehen könnt
schaut euch das mal an ja wir haben uns
ein bisschen was bei dem konzept gedacht
nämlich bei den farben dass es nicht
allzu gut sondern dass wir schön
bisschen bei den ertönen bleiben
bisschen bei den grünen ein bisschen
hier so terrakotta farben ein bisschen
gemischt mit ein bisschen gelb ocker ja
dass ich praktisch die farben noch mal
so ein bisschen wiederholen
ja und von den mustern her dass es so
ein bisschen orientalisch ist aber auch
nicht zu orientalisch dass man wenn man
sollte keine lust werden wir vielleicht
nächsten sommer oder nächsten früher
nicht mehr lust darauf hat dass man das
einfach noch mal austauschen kann oder
einfach auch noch mal wechseln kann
wichtig ist allerdings dabei dass wenn
ihr sowas nach dekoriert auch immer
einzeln beziehungsweise hier nimmt jetzt
nicht zwei stück hier fahren oder zwei
stück von dem gleichen muster nimmt am
besten immer einzelne kissen damit auch
wirklich auch ja eigentlich artig bleibt
schaut euch um was wir haben hier
verschiedene laternen da wird ein
bisschen orientalisch aussieht darüber
noch mal ein korn in der ecke damit man
noch mal ein bisschen die kisten noch
mal zusammen schmeißen kann falls man
hier ein bisschen um räumt und ihr könnt
was richtig richtig cool ist bei diesen
möbeln könnt ihr die nämlich wieder so
zusammenstellen dass hier eine richtig
schöne schlaf landschaft ja für schöne
sommerabende habt
[Musik]
also ja also ich bin ganz ehrlich welche
erwartungen hat komplett über trauriger
ich glaube ich kann behaupten das ist
das schönste bei conan in ganzen bochum
und ganz ruhig alex kunstwelt das wollt
mich sehr und er wir haben drin ja schon
einiges vorbereitet das heißt ist video
endet hier noch nicht es geht noch
weiter wir machen jetzt nämlich die
wohnküche und da kommen wir einfach mal
mit ja
[Musik]
hallo ja da werde ich mich nun wieder
und zwar wahrscheinlich kennt ihr diesen
bereich hier das ist nämlich kikis
kitchen sozusagen ihr arbeitsplatz und
mit sicherheit kommt euch das alles
etwas vertraut war aber in abgeänderter
form denn wir haben hier ein bisschen
das konzept geändert und zwar haben wir
ein paar farm rausgenommen um es ein
bisschen ruhiger zu gestalten
wenn ihr später und noch mal die gesamte
wohnung seht werdet ihr auch sehen dass
überall so ein bisschen der rote faden
mit drin ist und wir haben wirklich
nicht alle farben fast aus der küche
verbannt sondern haben versucht hier und
da noch mal ein bisschen was zu
integrieren und das zeige ich euch jetzt
hier wenn du nicht so ein bisschen also
wirklich das wieder gelassen wir haben
einige sachen neu gekauft aber ein paar
sachen damals eben auch gelassen wie zb
die tortenplatte diesen schönen behälter
der minoer sachen geändert und zwar
haben wir ein bisschen sie den roten
bereich so ein bisschen mit holz da hat
sie nach ruf nach wie vor ihre öle
stehen und ihre ganzen zutaten java noch
mal so ein bisschen eine kleine blaue
ecke gemacht wo wir noch mal ein paar
kleine accessoires mit aufgegriffen
haben also sollte nicht allzu schlicht
und allzu ton in ton werden genau oben
das wird euch jetzt wahrscheinlich
ziemlich neue vorkommen haben wir den
weltkrieges kitchen noch mal mit ins in
den bilderrahmen reingetan und hier auch
nochmal ein bisschen mehr mit grün
gearbeitet ein bisschen vielleicht ein
paar naturtöne und wir haben diesmal uns
überlegt dass wir vielleicht ein
bisschen drahtige sachen mit reinem
schwarz und zwar seht ihr das oben eine
tortenplatte die gibt es in die auch
richtiges kitchen hier auch nochmal zwei
wunderschöne kerzenhalter dass sie auch
ganz toll das wird wahrscheinlich
irgendwann das sind zwar künstliche
pflanzen vielleicht tauscht man die
irgendwann nochmal gegen echte kräuter
aus und schönes tablett noch eine schöne
platte und hier noch mal ein bisschen
mit holz gearbeitet das fliegen immer
noch mal so ein bisschen leben betreibt
und die rückwand ist halt eben nicht
immer ganz so leer und genau das haben
wir gemacht und eigentlich das highlight
haben wir hier vorne gemacht das ist
nämlich der essbereich bei kiki und
dammer uns überlegt dass er eigentlich
ein bisschen mehr höhe hin muss war ja
eigentlich alles relativ flach ist und
da mal mit einer schönen großen vase
gearbeitet mit ein paar behältern und
schön teller den sie schon hatte ja und
ein bisschen künstliche blumen könnt
auch frische nehmen wenn ihr lust habt
aber die bleiben immer so schön sie
sehen immer toll und drapiert aus ja ich
würde sagen dann hatte keeper nation mal
gucken was sie dazu sagen also ich muss
sagen ich halte mich hier was wirklich
am tag auf alle jahren aussah dass ich
ihr zu schlafen das ließ offen
und das ist halt nicht nur
arbeitsbereich sondern auch mit
wohnbereichen und ich hatte immer das
problem wir haben die trauer küche und
ich liebe das traue ich liebe die
arbeitsfläche die freundin das problem
ist ich wollte so ein bisschen grau
rausnehmen es die farbe einbringen und
dann habt ihr auch den videos gesehen
ich hatte da blau und pink und lila alle
farben im ganzen regenbogen und dass du
mir beigebracht dass man lieber ein
bisschen dezent hält die ein bisschen
weniger der weniger ist mehr und daher
in weißenfels schau genau daher habe ich
mich auch durch dich er hat schwarz in
die küche einzubüßen
weil ich nicht gedacht hätte dass es so
gut aussieht hast du denn noch so einen
kleinen tipp für alle die jetzt sagen
ich traue mich nicht oder irgendwie in
richtung farbpalette kannst du achten
jahr also was ich empfehlen kann auf
jeden fall
es sei denn man ist er ein richtiger
purist und minimalisten natürlich kann
man da natürlich immer in den gleichen
farben bleiben das sieht auch immer
schön aus aber wenn ihr so ein bisschen
struktur ein bisschen leben reinbringen
wollte würde ich immer sagen arbeitet
immer mit einer farbe die so ein
bisschen raus schicht also sprich immer
mit einer kontrastfarbe in dem fall
schwarz wurde ihr könnt auch vielleicht
mit hellen tönen im gegensatz zu
dunkelgrau arbeiten
aber das hier immer vielleicht eine
kontrast farbe und konzentriert euch
vielleicht auch einmal kommt ein oder
maximal konnte zwei kontrastfarben und
nicht zu viel weil dann ist es nämlich
so unruhig was kann ich eigentlich als
tipp mit käppi und der betrieb nehme ich
mir auch menschen fürs fotografieren bei
der food fotograf ist es auch so wenn
man lieber zwei kontrast der kontrast
von und nicht mehr genau dass das ist
übertragbar eigentlich alle bereiche
absolut apropos bereiche in der küche
ist nämlich auch noch unser wohnbereich
und das ist jetzt unsere nächste station
genau
okay da gemessen
[Musik]
hallo wir sind hier im wohnzimmer
angelangt und wir sind fertig geworden
tatsächlich wie ihr sehen könnt haben
wir hier schon eine schöne wanddicken
den tisch dekoriert wir haben ein
teppich da war vorher auch nicht da und
wir haben hier traumhafte kissen in
wunderschönen farben in samt ausgesucht
und das ganze sehr richtig stimmig auch
hier mit der gemütlichen lampe wenn das
oberlicht nicht gerade brennt
und ja wir haben nämlich eigentlich eine
farbe gesucht die zu den grau passt sie
hatte nämlich neues sofa und wir wussten
sie auch nicht welche farbe nehmen wir
uns gedacht okay also es hat auf jeden
fall vielleicht was flauschig etwas
gemütliches werden haben wir deshalb
samt genommen was auch nämlich richtig
richtig schön schimmert je nach
lichteinfall und sieht einfach gemütlich
aus und wir haben uns hier für dieses
blau entschieden für sohn pedro mit
seinem safran gelb und das passt
eigentlich auch immer das sieht im
winter schön gemütlich aus zu braucht
aber auch im früher mal gucken was geht
da zu sein
also ich muss den zuschauern ganz kurz
was erzählen hier erzählt wir standen
heute in diesem laden und haben die
goldene dekor ist das ist gold also gold
und beige und jetzt hab ich hab nur
gesagt zu dir herr auf der steinwand wie
soll das gehen
und du hast gesagt vertrau mir auch
leute wer hat nicht so viel versprochen
dass sie so genial auch ich meine wenn
ihr auf die idee gekommen
genauso wenig wie die kissen mit den
farben um ihr müsst euch vorstellen dass
ist mich alles aus einem laden das ist
nicht ein set was man so lernen könnte
nein es ist alles aus verschiedenen
leben einfach zusammengestellt und hat
ist das im gedächtnis
dann ist die vision und die setzen wir
hier und es passt einfach wie die faust
aufs das freut nicht so sehr dass dir
gefällt ja so er gehört dass ich über
ein bisschen vertrauen natürlich auch zu
aber ich habe meistens wenn ich mir
überlege tatsächlich auch immer ein
konzept vor augen oder auch die farben
also selbst in den verschiedenen shops
gehen habe ich ganz klar vor augen
welche farben welche farblose ganz genau
zueinander passt und ja genau stimmen
aus und natürlich gefällt ist dass heute
definitiv und ich haben sind auch zum
ersten mal zum ersten inneneinrichterin
an meiner seite ich kannte das ja alles
vorher gar nicht und ich bin so froh
dass du ja ist ein richtiges ist auch
ein bisschen schwierig weil die gucken
direkt auf die küche diesen halben meter
von uns entfernt ja von euch das später
noch einen ganzen und es ist schwierig
da eben diesen ja dass dieses
zwischending rauszuwerfen
es ist schön übergang auf zuschauer ganz
zu schaffen und dazu erzählt uns
vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen was wie
sich immer so ein bisschen alles wieder
findet den einzelnen räumlichkeiten
aber wir haben ja noch das i-tüpfelchen
den flur wenn wir dahin kommen
[Musik]
nur im flur angekommen ja ich hab noch
nie so ein hübsches vorgesehen ist etwa
so ich mache meine arbeit ist in solch
stolz drauf wie kannst du setzen die
einzelelemente auch wieder aus 34
verschiedene nehmen ja ja ich wir haben
uns ein bisschen unterhalten im
vorhinein und ich weiß ja von dir auch
das so ein bisschen dieses orientalische
auch ein bisschen liebst und es sollte
aber auch nicht zu orientalisch werden
also genau das eigentlich was ich eben
im auch bei kunden mich schon erzählt
habe das ist so ein hauch orientalen ja
tal intouch praktisch hat aber auch
nicht zu sehr und deswegen kann man
diesen schönen spiegel also naja
orientalist sind nicht wirklich so ein
bisschen er so indisch leicht aber es
halt eben sehr sehr schön wir haben
deshalb wie werden eigentlich eine
auswahl zwischen zwei spiegeln nämlich
einen richtig orientalischen so aus
messing also so richtig mit seinem bogen
und so aber der wahrheiten länglich
gewesen die haben aber hier ein sehr
relativ breiten flur der sehr lang ist
und mussten den so ein bisschen
praktisch mit leben füllen und haben uns
deshalb für diesen hier entschieden weil
er entsprechend relativ lang ist ich
glaube jetzt circa 70 glaub ich genau wo
es entsprechend glaube ich gefallen hat
und lange ja richtig und deshalb haben
uns für den spiegel entschieden und ein
bisschen was schlicht ist hier noch mit
dazu
wir wollten es nie auch nicht ganz so
sehr überladen mit am boden oder mit
dicken schränken oder so sondern des
wollens erst ein bisschen fluffig
filigran halten ja und deshalb hat eben
mit den schülern agenten hier hat sie
sich noch mal ein schönes mitbringsel
aus marrakesch mitgebracht und das passt
also je ist das zusammen abi und es ist
wieder nicht eins etwas man so von der
stadt was so im leben steht sondern du
hast gesagt das passt am nächsten tag
habe mir das gefühl genau bei mir zu
hause das trotzdem
die ganze ding auseinander gerückt
ja und ich jeden teppiche haben wir auch
noch geholt wollten ja auch etwas was
auch so ein bisschen das muster noch ein
bisschen widerspiegelt genau das muster
das genau hier im entstehen ein bisschen
für mich genau so was haben wir hier im
herz meine wohnung in der küche und
jetzt ich weiß ganz genau ihr stellt
euch jetzt nur die eine frage wie kommen
wir an dieser fahrern wie kann man nicht
buchen eigentlich relativ einfach er
bucht mich einfach unter safferling
punkt de oder über man instagram seite
oder oder wir schreiben einfach alles in
die infobox
na dann haben was alles schriftlich und
ich bin mir sicher dass du zahlreiche
anfragen kriegen willst weil ich so also
ich sage es doch was hände sind aus gold
und erledigt und die also die den blick
dafür hat sie einfach und ich glaube das
muss auch wirklich verankert sein das
muss man einfach können und das kannst
du und ich hoffe oder wir hoffen dass
euch das video gefallen hat und dass sie
ein daumen nach oben gelassen wenn das
video gefallen hat hinterlasst doch
gerne ein kommentar wie ihr die
einrichtung findet ja und ja ansonsten
wünschen wir euch noch einen
wunderschönen tag und bis zum nächsten
video ist stoff hallstatt
wir haben wir haben was ganz wichtig ist
vergessen den ford stimmt denn man ja
komm doch mal her
das ist der vorrat der hand von der
linie safa und die zwei sind wie haben
sie eigentlich immer im doppelpack noch
fleißig mitgeholfen und ich glaube dass
jede sache ein starke ford an der seite
oder
das ist der heilige also ihr buch quasi
die zwei im doppelpack genau
bis 22